his leg look broke look at
leg look at his leg that boy leg look
broke his leg broke and y'all dragging
him like that I heard this boy Hing and
screaming get off of me get off of me
you hurting my neck you're hurting my
neck get your knee out my back shut
that's what the police said
[Applause]
to
at the end of the day I don't want him
to be a Freddy gray but to stand up
there and vandalize police officers get
over here that that's not
[Applause]
Justice
he's going to Hur that police there we
[Music]
go so the officers seem to be unfaced
about it they seem to be unfed they're
moving forward um hopefully that fire
will be put out do not give them reason
15 structure fires there's no excuse for
that kind of violence right yeah and
there's no excuse for the seven people
that the Baltimore City police
department has killed in the past year
either right we're not making
comparisons obviously we don't want
anybody hurt but I just want to hear you
say that there should be peaceful
protests not violent protests in the
tradition of Dr Martin Luther King yeah
there should be peaceful protest and I I
don't have to uh condone it to
understand it right that the the pain
that people feel is real and and you are
making a comparison you are suggesting
this idea that broken windows um are are
worse than broken spines right he's a
photographer he's PR photographer he's a
[Applause]
photographer this ain't doing
nothing
[Applause]
come back in here come in this right
here is not relevant they need to have
their butts at home and doing something
with their life mama and daddy didn't
lost a child that could be
them
oh here comes a SWAT
team SWAT team SWAT SWAT SWAT this game
we'll see Jim we're going to be able to
go out and get a lot of souvenir tonight
we won't have any comp and even though
the fans can't come in to see the ball
game at least got involved in some of
this he signed a fake autograph go home
please be home by 10:00
don't give anybody an excuse to do
something that's not right eyes on them
and how they're handling this they
impose a curfew so what it appears to me
that Baltimore is trying to do what did
you did you see that what's going
on he wasn't almost hit by that armored
vehicle they drove the vehicle up and
when it got close enough to create a
wedge they ran out and grabbed him
pinned him against that and then
arrested him they must have uh perceived
rightly or wrongly we don't know know
but that he was part of this group that
was throwing things at them when he
tried to come up the street the first
time with his uh his hands up they were
shooting the pepper bullets at him and
he ran back with this other
[Applause]
[Music]
group
in
here
[Music]
kind of um activity at this point so the
the police officers actually ran towards
this
Crow
[Music]
the situation in Baltimore right now I
think is uh pretty much under the
control of the of the National Guard and
the police the curfew will be in effect
tonight uh it's bad it's it's very bad a
lot of damage unnecessary damage was
done uh certainly to no one's benefit we
try we try to keep the greatest number
possible on the streets and at the same
time maintain an adequate Reserve which
does not answer any questions what plans
do you have for your men this afternoon
and tonight well we certainly intend to
keep them uh in
action understand
lonely